[MUSIC PLAYING]
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: When you have
a data-intensive applications,
such as health insurance, and
your on-premise traditional
data warehouse does not quite
fit the pace and the wallet
with which your data science
team wants to innovate,
you know it's time to migrate
your data warehouse to Cloud.
So today, I invited
Gary Morreale, director
of Data Services
team, to share with us
how they migrated their
data warehouse to BigQuery
to innovate faster.
Hi, Gary.
Welcome to the show.
GARY MORREALE: Hi.
Thanks for having me.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Well, let's
start with what is your role.
GARY MORREALE: Sure.
What my team does, the
Data Services team,
is we support all of the
databases at the organization.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: So I imagine
it is large amount of data.
As a data team, what's your
team's biggest challenge?
GARY MORREALE: So
our biggest challenge
is getting that data
into our databases
and then getting it back
out in a timely fashion
so we can meet the
businesses' needs.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: So
how much amount of data
are we talking about here?
GARY MORREALE: We're talking
about terabytes of data.
And it's continuously growing.
As everybody in the
industry probably knows,
it's got an exponential
curve to it.
And it's getting
bigger all the time.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: So it sounds
like the biggest goal was
to really create a
forward-looking system
to store this ever-growing data
in a secure, scalable, and also
cost-effective manner.
GARY MORREALE: So getting
that data in and out
and making that data available
to all of our users--
we have thousands of users
and terabytes of data.
And meeting those challenges
was getting harder and harder
in our existing environment.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: So
migration from on-premise data
warehouse to BigQuery
is quite an undertaking,
definitely not flip of a
switch kind of migration.
You need to make sure
your downstream systems--
in this case, thousands
of downstream systems--
don't break due to inconsistent
results in your final tables
after your migration.
So how did you approach
this migration?
GARY MORREALE: So we
engaged Datametica,
one of Google's
business partners,
to help us complete an
assessment of everything
we have today, which included
not just our data warehouse,
but all the applications that
use it and all of the processes
that pull data in
and take data out.
And they were able to
come back and give us
a complete picture
of what it was we
were going to be dealing with.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Well, after
hearing that solid migration
plan, I'm very excited to
dive into the migration
architecture.
It sounds like this is an
ongoing migration right now.
Walk me through.
GARY MORREALE: So the
first thing we had to do
was put the foundation in place.
So that involved getting our
networking set up, getting
the environment
in Google set up,
all the connections between
the different environments here
and there between our
data center and Google--
so we got all of that in place.
And then once that
was there, then we
were able to start working
on moving the data over.
So we have all the data
in our existing system.
And we used a transfer agent
to transfer to BigQuery moves.
And that allowed us to pull
the data into Cloud Storage.
And then from there, the data
went into data quality checks
via Dataflow, which
allowed us to move
the data into the environment.
We were able to
set that scheduling
up using Cloud Composer to do
scheduling and orchestration as
well.
Then we got it into
the staging environment
in BigQuery, which allowed
us to push it into our core
environment and
then our information
layer so that our end
users would have access
to everything.
And then we have to worry
about keeping everything
in sync because while we're in
the migration process, which
will go on for some time,
we need to make sure
that what was happening
in the old system
is what's happening
in the new system.
And Pelican is the
tool with a GKE cluster
that allows us to do that
comparison between the two
and make sure things
stay in sync, which has
been a really good feature--
gives us a lot of confidence
in what we're doing.
And then the end
result of all of this
is that our consumers on the
final end of this journey--
people using SQL Server
Reporting Services, Tableau,
other applications
we've written,
or third-party applications--
are able to now just point at
BigQuery instead of pointing
at our existing system and
do the same things that they
were doing previously.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
Well, awesome.
That was a lot.
Now, given your consumers
of the data, which
is the data scientists and
the business analytics team,
you have this modern data
warehouse in BigQuery
at this point.
How do you ingest
and process the data?
And then how do data science
and business analytics team
do their job, which is analyze
this data and make predictions?
GARY MORREALE: Sure.
Well, we have a lot of
different data sources.
Being a health insurer, we get
data from various providers,
like hospitals and
doctors' offices,
testing centers,
things like that.
We also get data
from our members.
And then we have a lot of
processing business partners
that we work as well
as government entities.
So we needed a way to set up
secure file transfers, which
we can do.
And we can load that
into Cloud Storage
and then use API-based services,
as well, to do the same thing.
And then we can move
that using Dataproc
with our Hadoop-type
environments
that we're used to using to
load the data up into BigQuery.
So now we've got
everything in place.
And the data scientists
can then use the tools
that they're used to
using, which, in this case,
would be the Vertex artificial
intelligence pipelines that
are provided in the
Google environment.
They use Jupyter Notebooks
to work with all of that.
They're able to take
advantage of the fact
that it's not a static
environment, like we
had before.
So they can add resources.
For example, GPUs become a huge
benefit in this environment
to data scientists.
So they can dynamically
add them as needed.
And then what they end
up doing in the end
is they build models that
help us assess and do
preventative care,
understand what's
going on with our pharmacies,
what risks people may have,
what kind of fraud
might be going on.
It just allows them
to do the magic
that it is-- the
data scientists do
and understanding
how all this data
can be put to use to make
our members' health better.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
That is amazing.
So what is next in
this architecture?
And what's your
team working on now?
GARY MORREALE: So
the nice thing is now
that we have this
foundation in place
with the security, the
networking, all of that,
we can start to look at what
other types of opportunities
there might be.
So we've been looking at
voice recognition software.
We've been looking at different
types of reporting tools
that are provided up there.
There's just a whole host
of different applications
that are provided on
the Google platform
that we can now easily put
into place compared to before,
having to buy different
hardware in our own data center.
So it just presents a
lot of opportunities.
And we're looking
at a lot of them.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Well, now
that everything is in one place
and your infrastructure
layers are all
set up, you can just innovate on
top of that, which is amazing.
Thank you so much, Gary.
And we congratulate you for
what you have accomplished, you
and the team have accomplished.
And we look forward
to seeing more updates
on this architecture.
GARY MORREALE: Great.
Thank you.
It's been great
talking to you today.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: If you have
any specific topics or industry
architectures you
would like me to cover,
put them in the comments,
and I will bring them to you.